[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
maman ne voulait pas que je raconte
cette histoire ça lui faisait peur et
elle se sentait déjà terriblement
coupable
à tort car maman n'est coupable de rien
mais quand je lui ai dit tu sais je
pense que je vais raconter cette
histoire dans une chronique à la radio
elle m'a dit n'en s'il te plaît ne dit
rien c'est déjà assez compliqué comme ça
c'est déjà assez douloureux pour nous et
puis nous pour l'instant on n'a pas
d'autre solution s'il te plaît ne dit
rien tu va envenimer les choses qu'est
ce qu'ils vont dire là bas s'il tentante
s'ils entendent ce que tu racontes s'il
te plaît ne dit rien donc d'abord je
n'ai rien je suis journaliste et je
travaille à france inter depuis
plusieurs saisons je présente la revue
de presse du week-end est une chronique
le vendredi matin un peu avant 7h ça
s'appelle le quart d'heure de célébrité
dans cette chronique chaque semaine je
dresse le portrait d'une personne
subitement propulsé à la une de
l'actualité un inconnu
une inconnue devenus brusquement célèbre
parfois il y aurait plusieurs qui
surgissent la même semaine pour ma
chronique c'est formidable je n'ai que
l'embarras du choix
et puis certaines semaines je rame je
cherche
ça y est les journaux j'écoute les
radios je regardais télévision je surf
sur internet je trouve pas c'est
difficile je pleure je désespère et
c'est ce qui s'est produit
il y a un an précisément la première
semaine de décembre
et comme je ne trouvais pas d'inconnus
pas de sujet pour cette chronique le
quart d'heure de célébrité j'ai décidé
de faire ce qu en temps normal un
journaliste n'est pas censé faire
j'ai choisi de raconter une histoire
familiale
cette histoire comme un homme avait dit
au départ qu'elle ne souhaitait pas que
je le raconte
parce qu'elle avait peur et parce
qu'elle culpabiliser mais après
réflexion et après en avoir discuté avec
ses soeurs elle m'a dit c'est toi qui as
raison si tu veux parler tu as notre
autorisation
et puis on a trouvé une autre solution
on a trouvé un autre établissement ce
vendredi 8 décembre 2010 est un peu
avant 7 heures
j'ai donc raconté à l'antenne de france
inter
l'histoire de suzanne la chronique ça
donnait un petit peu ça suzanne à 95 ans
et elle a toujours aimé la vie même si
la vie pour elle n'a pas toujours été
simple
elle a perdu 1,6 quand il était bébé ait
perdu son mari quand elle même avait 40
ans il était avocat
ils travaillaient ensemble
il faisait du tennis ensemble ils
voyageaient ensemble ils allaient au
théâtre ensemble ils avaient des amis il
aimait faire la fête
parfois des fêtes costumées chanter et
danser boire du champagne mais lorsque
pierre est mort c'est seul que susan a
dû élever ses quatre filles auxquelles
elle a tenté d'inculquer l'essentiel
faire bonne figure toujours et en toutes
circonstances garder son sens de
l'humour ça de ville csq m
sourire quand même sourire malgré les
drames les douleurs de la vie depuis
tout petit a bis à une amie ne va pas
bien lui dit sqm sourire même quand elle
était encore alerte suzanne aimé par
ailleurs prendre le volant et rouler
vite très vite beaucoup trop vite
elle aurait adoré faire des rallies
automobiles
quand elle était encore alerte suzanne
aimé par ailleurs se mettre aux
fourneaux faire de grandes tablées des
plats en sauce surtout et de la cuisine
à la crème on ne renie pas ses origines
elle est née en normandie à
sainte-adresse juste à côté du havre un
lundi de pentecôte le 5 juin 1922
mais depuis quelques temps susan a
commencé à perdre l'équilibré allé
plusieurs fois tombée des cassures des
foulures des séjours dans les hôpitaux
et les maisons de convalescence
à son retour chez elle des infirmières
venait le matin ou soir des aides
ménagères venait le matin et le soir on
a transformé sa baignoire en douche à
l'italienne
on lui faisait livrer des repas le midi
mais si jeanne a continué de tomber de
plus en plus souvent et alors qu'elle
l'avait répété des années durant qu'elle
préférait se tendre que de finir sa vie
dans une maison de retraite
elle a finalement admis qu'il était
devenu très dangereux de rester seule
chez elle et qu'elle avait besoin d'un
encadrement médical
adieu l'appartement adieu les tapis
adieu les tableaux adieu les
bibliothèques remplies de souvenirs
début 2010 est suzanne s'est résigné à
s'installer dans un ehpad établissement
d'hébergement pour personnes âgées
dépendantes
certes ces petits dit elle mais ce n'est
pas ce qui me dérange le plus
[Musique]
non ce qui la dérange d'abord c'est la
nourriture insipide indigne dit elle
tout ressemble à de la bouillie même à
des animaux on n'oserait pas servir des
plats aussi mauvais elle dit qu'elle ne
sait pas ce cas là dans son assiette à
ne sais pas si c'est de la viande ou du
poisson
elle dit que même pendant la guerre elle
manger mieux et pour le fromage on n'a
même pas d'assiettes il nous le mettre
directement dans la main ça aussi ça la
choque ce qu'ils en supportent aussi
c'est la manière qu'on a de s'adresser à
elle
il arrive qu'on l'appelle petite mamie
n'est juste pas leur petite mamie il ya
aussi cette aide soignante qu'ils
l'aident à s'habiller et qui la brusque
pour qu'elle se dépêche de choisir ses
vêtements et quand suzanne lui dis tel
vêtement tel autre elle lui dit d'abord
on dit s'il vous plaît infantilisation
d'une femme de 95 ans quant à celles qui
s'occupent de nettoyer sa chambre elle
se plaint tous les jours de la salle de
bains qui ne serait pas assez propre
et elle est allée jusqu'à lui mettre
sous le nez des matières fécales en lui
disant vous pouvez me dire ce que c'est
que ça l'humiliation d'une femme de 95
ans des excréments sous le nez je pense
qu'on peut appeler ça de la maltraitance
dans ma chronique je raconte est
également l'état piteux du bâtiment
l'ascenseur qui tombe en panne le
vaudais de la chambre qui reste bloqué
en position fermée pendant plusieurs
semaines j'évoquais la toilette pour
suzanne une douche de cinq minutes par
semaine
j'évoquais le flacon de parfum qui
disparaît subitement et j'évoquais le
personnel débordé manque de temps manque
de moyens un personnel épuisé un métier
éreintant et payé une misère
cette chronique je disais ça et là en
france pas partout heureusement on
maltraite nos vieux dans une
indifférence quasi générale
c'est un scandale d'état et donc il faut
parler parler pour suzanne mais aussi
pour germaine pour léon pour gustave
pour gérard pour martin pour françoise
pour robert et parler pour les autres
aussi pour les prochaines générations
à la fin de ma chronique je signalais
que susan avait bientôt déménager dans
un nouvel établissement
et puis je conclurai en dix ans depuis
qu'elle a quitté son domicile suzanne a
perdu 20 kilos et moins quelques grammes
d'humour parce que suzanne c'est ma
grand mère dès que j'ai quitté le studio
que je suis retourné à mon bureau
j'avais déjà des dizaines de mails sur
mon ordinateur le soir il y en avait des
centaines et dans les jours qui ont
suivi j'ai reçu
là encore des centaines de messages des
milliers sur les réseaux sociaux et de
longues lettres manuscrites
parmi ces courriers il y avait des
courriers de directeurs d'ehpad qui me
disait chez moi je vous assure ça ne se
passe pas comme ça chez moi les
résidents sont heureux il y avait des
courriers de soignants qui me disais
dans mon établissement ça ne se passe
pas comme ça ici on accepte les animaux
de compagnie par exemple ici on fait
quand une commune avec les enfants de
l'école d'à côté les générations
dialogue c'est formidable un autre
m'écrivait que dans son établissement y
avait des animations nocturnes pour ceux
qui sont un peu déboussolés ou qui sont
insomniaques si jeanne est insomniaque
ali jusqu'au matin mais l'essentiel des
témoignages que j'ai reçus étaient des
appels de détresse et des remerciements
des gens qui me remercient d'avoir pris
la parole qui me disait vous visiblement
vous écoute nous ne nous écoute pas des
gens qui tenait à me raconter l'histoire
de leur papa l'histoire de leur maman
l'histoire de leurs grands parents de
leur oncle de leur tante de leurs femmes
de leur mari et là j'ai découvert que ce
qu'avait pu vivre suzanne c'était rien
par rapport à ce que pouvaient subir
d'autres dans d'autres établissements
pas dans tous les établissements
mais dans certains trop nombreux en
france
en lisant ces témoignages j'ai appris
beaucoup de choses peut-être que vous
vous le saviez mais moi je ne savais pas
par exemple que dans certains
établissements mais des protections
résidents quand il arrive tout
simplement parce qu'on n'a pas le temps
de les emmener aux toilettes on les rend
un continent et comme on fait des
économies sur les protections parce
qu'on fait des économies surtout ils
n'ont droit qu'à trois ou quatre
protection par jour et il peut arriver
qu'il reste des heures dans des
protections soulier peut-être que vous
vous le saviez mais moi je ne savais pas
dans certains établissements les
soignants sont obligés de nourrir trois
ou quatre résidents en même temps et
donc les gaz
ils mélangent l'entrée le plat pour
aller plus vite peut-être que vous le
saviez mais moi je ne savais pas dans
certains établissements il ya des
résidents qu'on ne lève plus de leur lit
pas à cette personnel madame martin n'a
pas de famille madame martin n'a pas de
visite
madame martin est très compliqué à lever
à billets madame martin on va la laisser
dans son lit
trois jours sur quatre peut-être que
vous le saviez mais moi je savais pas
que certains établissements fonctionnent
avec des fonds de pension que leurs buts
c'est la rentabilité s'est pas forcément
dans ces établissements là que ça se
passe le plus mal peut-être que vous le
saviez moi je savais pas que les patrons
de ces grands groupes figuraient parmi
les plus grosses fortunes de france
peut-être que vous le savez moi je
savais pas que les soignants qui
travaillent dans les ehpad sont plus
souvent blessé que ceux qui travaillent
dans le bâtiment
peut-être que vous lui il s'agit moi je
ne savais pas que des résidents meurent
de faim parfois dans les ehpad en france
il ne mange pas non pas parce que c'est
mauvais il ne mange pas parce qu'il n'y
a pas assez de personnel pour les aider
à lever la fourchette
je savais pas tout ça et je ne savais
pas que l'histoire de suzanne allait
déclencher autant de témoignages et je
savais pas que ça concernait autant
d'établissements dans toutes les régions
de france des établissements publics des
établissements associatifs ou privés à
but lucratif
je savais pas qu'il y avaient autant
d'histoires je savais pas qu'autant de
gens se taisent et simplement en disant
on ne nous écoute pas parce qu'on parle
de vieilles personnes et que le vieil
personnes intéresse personne parce que
c'est pas sexy
le grand âge et parce qu'on veut pas le
voir c'est nous plus tard
donc tout le monde sait que ça se passe
mal en certains endroits tout le monde
vit des choses très douloureuse tout le
monde connaît quelqu'un qui a un parent
pour qui ça se passe mal mais n'en
parlons pas c'est trop douloureux
je me suis rendu compte aussi que la
plupart de ces témoignages étaient et
témoignages de détresse féminine parce
que dans ces maisons de retraite
il y a plus de femmes que d'hommes les
femmes vivent plus longtemps parce que
dans ces maisons de retraite le
personnel est un personnel féminin pour
l'essentiel et parce que souvent ce sont
les filles qui accompagnent leurs
parents vieillissants donc la détresse
qui se manifeste dans ces circonstances
là c'est surtout une détresse féminine
si les résidents étaient essentiellement
des hommes si les soignants étaient
essentiellement des hommes si c'était
les hommes qui s'occupait
essentiellement de leurs parents à ce
que les pouvoirs publics mettrait
davantage d'argent
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peut-être parmi les témoignages qui
m'ont le plus touché c'était des
témoignages de soignants qui me disait
on n'a même pas le temps de parler avec
les résidents on ne sait pas qui ils
sont on connaît à peine leur pathologie
mais on ne sait même pas qu'ils sont ne
connaît pas leur histoire et en lisant
ça je me suis dit je dois pas m'arrêter
à cette chronique je vais rendre son
histoire à suzanne j'écris un livre ce
livre s'appelle suzanne
c'est l'avis de ma grand mère je lui
rends sa vie cette vie ignoré dans
l'établissement où elle a passé neuf
mois
avec elle on a fouillé dans sa mémoire
le livre raconte son enfance dans les
années 20 où wavre son adolescence dans
les années trente à quand la guerre à
laval 4 ans d'occupation la rencontre
avec son mari son mari qui meurent les
rêves de susan elle voulait être
comédienne elle voulait voir new york
les faire des rallies automobiles je le
disais tout à l'heure je raconte suzanne
telle qu'elle fut petite fille suzanne
telle qu'elle fut femme épouse et je
raconte suzanne la merveilleuse grand
mère qu'elle est devenue et que j'ai la
chance d'avoir toujours suzanne a lu le
livre à la lui les passages concernant
son enfance hamadi jeu très intéressant
ta bonne mémoire dit donc j'aime ce pas
ma mémoire c'est la tienne
je voulais callies aussi devant les
passages difficiles la mort de son fils
la mort de son mari ou la scène intime
que j'ai écrite une scène d'amour entre
ma grand mère et mon grand père c'est
assez délicat
mais je les ai écrit le livre raconte la
france aussi à travers la traversée du
siècle de zidane mais aussi l'évolution
du rôle de la femme et la scène d'amour
raconte une femme qui n'a jamais connu
le plaisir
suzanne a lu le livre ce chapitre là
elle m'a dit c'est exactement ça après
je les prévenus que quelques passages
étaient un peu romancée c'est un peu un
roman c'est le roman de sa vie
et puis je lui dis tu sais l'héroïne ne
peut pas être non plus totalement
parfaite donc il ya des passages où je
me manque un peu de toi parce que tu as
aussi les côtes est insupportable il
commence à faiblir
elle a lu alors fermé lundi tout va bien
et que c'était romancée
et puis dont le livre devant - là lui
aussi les chapitres qui concernait le
quotidien qu'elle a pu avoir à les
panais et chaque scène racontée la
remise en colère dans une grande colère
chaque fois l es tu te rends compte tu
te rends compte dans quelles conditions
j'étais tu te rends compte dans quelles
conditions nous sommes à chaque fois ça
a réveillé sa colère elle me dit porte
cette colère tu es tu es là pour
raconter ne t'ai pas parle parle pour
moi mais parle aussi pour les autres
pour ceux qui n'ont personne à qui
raconter pour ceux qui n'ont même plus
la capacité de parler et donc ce livre
il est pour suzanne certes mais aussi
pour toutes les femmes de cette
génération et tous les hommes de cette
génération
ils sont notre histoire ils ont fabriqué
notre pays on leur doit au moins une fin
de vie dans la meilleure des dignité
dans le livre je raconte que l'oncle de
suzanne est mort pour la france en 14
ans n'est tranché il voir pour la france
dans le livre je raconte que les parents
de suzanne ont résisté en 44 il cachait
des armes des barres à justice anglais
ils ont participé à la libération de la
france
pourquoi ce cas elle n'aurait pas le
droit de terminer sa vie de façon digne
et les autres et les autres donc je
porte sa colère et la colère est
d'autant plus forte que dans d'autres
endroits peut être majoritaire
ça se passe très bien donc il est
possible de bien faire la bien traitance
est possible elle est possible mais
peut-être que c'est à nous d'agir tant
qu'elles soient générale pour qu'elle
soit totale pour que tous les
établissements fonctionnent bien les
pouvoirs publics n'ont pas anticipé le
fait que pour la première fois depuis le
début du manitou nous vivons aujourd'hui
sur cinq générations
nous nous c'est ce cheminement vers une
génération de centenaires jusque-là ça
s'était jamais vu donc une génération du
très très grand âge avec des pathologies
qu'on ne connaissait pas jusque là
les soignants ne sont pas formés pour
ces pathologies là et on n'a pas
anticipé le fait qu'on allait vivre sur
cinq générations
est ce que moi je veux que mes parents
ils connaissent que suzanne inconnu non
est ce que je veux ça pour moi
non non non non non alors c'est oui
c'est pas joli mais parlons-en
mais réfléchissons imaginons d'autres
choses un seul chiffre
aujourd'hui en france il y à un million
deux cent mille personnes qui ont plus
de 85 ans on n'est pas forcément
dépendant à 85 ans on peut aller très
bien
mais un million deux cent mille
personnes en 2060 dans quarante ans
demain il y aura 5 millions en france
deux personnes de plus de 85 ans le
chiffre est multiplié par quatre
moi j'aurais 85 ans si je suis toujours
là précisément 85 ans en 2060
est ce qu'on peut se satisfaire que
certains établissements dysfonctionne à
ce point comme on n'a pas anticipé vont
s'ouvrir de plus en plus
d'établissements et donc on s'achemine
vers des dérives multiples si on
anticipe à qu'il faut aller vers le
bien-être une association existe depuis
30 ans maintenant
elle s'appelle humanitude elle forme les
soignants à la bientraitance parce que
ça te monde une formation elle distribue
ce label il ya 18 établissements en
france pour l'instant qui ont ce label
humanitude une centaine d'établissements
le réclament cette association forme à
la bientraitance
comment on s'adresse à une personne âgée
comme on la porte sans se blesser soi
même sans la blesser comme on lui fait
une toilette sans se blesser sans lui
faire mal comment on respecte son rythme
biologique
elle se passe le vers 7 heures parce
qu'elle dort on va pas la lever à 7h
sous prétexte que tout le monde doit
elle réveille à cette heure comment on
respecte son rythme biologique pour les
repas elle n'a pas faim à midi elle
mangera 14h et comment on respecte aussi
son histoire en lui demandant de
raconter les lecteurs qui ont lu le
vivre pour l'instant me dis je referme
le livre j'appelle ma grand mère
d'autres me dis-je leur ferme je vais
voir ma grand mère julie excuse moi j'ai
plein de questions à se poser
il faut qu'on change le regard sur le
très grand âge ce ne sont pas que des
gradés mater et non pas toujours aux 90
ou 95 ans ils ont eu cinq en dix ans 20
ans ce sont simplement des petits
enfants qui ont grandi
qui ont vivier qui sont un peu abîmée
certes mais ils ont encore à nous
apprendre
et si on ne regarde autrement
globalement notre société et traitera
aussi différents de façon différente
je pense que c'est notre responsabilité
aujourd'hui je pense que c'est une
urgence nationale
cinq millions de personnes depuis 85 ans
en 2060 et je pense que nous tous on
doit imaginer les choses pour qu'à
l'avenir il n'y ait plus de suzanne qui
j'ai des choses déplorable dans les
établissements pour que toutes les
suzanne continue à grandir dans
l'intimité et que tout les sujets jeunes
continuent malgré leur grand âge de
sourire quand même
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bon